Christopher Nolan's Oppenheimer throws a
lot at the audience in a good way from
the significance of horses to the use of
Moody black and white scenes there's
more to Oppenheimer than meets the eye
at the beginning of the movie we follow
a young J Robert Oppenheimer during his
studies in physics across Europe while
at Cambridge Oppenheimer is severely
depressed and becomes frustrated with
his highly critical instructor future
Nobel Prize winner Patrick blacker in an
unthinkable fit of anger he injects an
apple on the professor's desk with
deadly potassium cyanide Oppenheimer
quickly regrets the decision and races
back to the classroom to dispose of the
Apple only to find his Idol Niels boar
holding it thankfully the whole affair
ends quietly without anyone taking a
bite although dramatized this bizarre
event is basing Real History
oppenheimer's poor mental health at
Cambridge is well documented and
according to various reports he did
attempt to poison one of blackett's
apples a severity of the actual
encounter is debated and it wasn't
necessarily anything as dangerous as
cyanide the inclusion of bore is a
fictional addition from Christopher
Nolan but the kernel of the story
remains true like Memento Christopher
Nolan's second film some scenes in
Oppenheimer are in full color and others
are in black and white if you're
familiar with this password work you
might assume that the division is being
used in the same way as the earlier
movie to differentiate between two
different points in time at first that
holds somewhat true with the black and
white scenes all taking place after the
Manhattan Project however the theory
doesn't totally hold up oppenheimer's
hearing is shot in color despite taking
place well after World War II by the end
of the movie we even get versions of the
same scenes in both color and black and
white the real distinction seems to be
that the black and white scenes show
things from the perspective of Lewis
Strauss the primary villain of the film
in its final act his Congressional
hearing and all of his meetings are shot
in black and white as are his versions
of different encounters with Oppenheimer
early in the film before he's recruited
to lead the Manhattan Project
oppenheimer's primary area of study is
black holes and neutron stars at the
party where he first meet Gene tadlock
he's knee-deep in black hole research
clearly fascinated by the inherent
paradoxes of the field when Asti says
that he's studying how Stars die adding
the bigger the star the more dramatic
its demise this line isn't just science
but a grim bit of foreshadowing for how
oppenheimer's own life will end up after
becoming the most famous scientist in
the world for my marriage reasons he
tries to remedy the damage but fails
frustrated by his outspoken opposition
to continued nuclear weapons development
the US government effectively blacklists
him the star of the country who helped
him win the war is ostracized the
gravity of his notoriety collapsing in
on itself there's a second sad
significance to oppenheimer's Black Hole
research which is that several of his
contemporaries believed he might have
won a Nobel Prize and he continued
exploring that area of quantum physics
instead he largely abandoned the field
and became much better known for the
Manhattan Project though Oppenheimer was
nominated for the award several times in
his life he never won it General Leslie
Groves is one of the major players of
Oppenheimer he recruits Oppenheimer to
help the Manhattan Project and is a
driving force in finally getting him his
security clearance this is the most
important thing to ever happen in the
history of the world additionally he
offers genuine advice to Oppenheimer on
the FBI and other intelligence folks
start poking around his life Groves also
plays a lessover role as a measure of
time in the film over the course of the
Manhattan Project we see Groves visibly
rise through the ranks at his first
meeting with Oppenheimer he's still just
a colonel but he tells the physicist
that he's being promoted to General for
his work on the project we then observe
grows at the Brigadier General and
eventually a major general will not
solve these things but the ranks are
shown on his uniform marking the passage
of time at Las Alamos in a movie that
otherwise does all it can to murder its
chronology Rose retired as an honorary
Lieutenant General a ranky held after
retirement when testifying oppenheimer's
security hearings though he starred in a
ton of major movies over the years
Killian Murphy may be best known today
for his leading role of Thomas Shelby
and the British crime drama peaky
blinders set in the wake of World War
One the series follows a Birmingham
Street gang as it ascends to
International prominence under the
leadership of Murphy's character Jay
Robert Oppenheimer is a very different
character than Tommy Shelby however
there is one big similarity between the
two they both find solace in their
relationships with horses and peaky
blinders Tommy is arguably more
comfortable around the animals than he
is around any single human he has a deep
love and respect for horses that helps
him occasionally escape from his
stressful criminal life in much the same
way Murphy's Oppenheimer seems happiest
when out peacefully in the New Mexico
desert with a horse the rest of his life
becomes an unceasing procession of guilt
and death after the Manhattan Project
when he's out alone with a horse however
Oppenheimer seems to find some
Tranquility this almost certainly isn't
an intentional reference as it merely
reflects a true aspect of oppenheimer's
life but given that Tommy Shelby is
probably Murphy's most famous role the
similarity stands out as a notable
detail after his initial relationship
with Gene tatlock ends Oppenheimer
marries Kitty things go well at first
but life gets tough after they have
their first child Peter Oppenheimer is
off organizing the early stages of the
Manhattan Project and he comes home from
one night to find their infant son
screaming and kitty drunk at the dining
room table she explains that he's been
crying all night distress and unsure
what to do Oppenheimer takes his son to
the house of Berkeley colleague and good
friend akanchavalier who watches over
the child for a time for the rest of his
infancy is depicted in the film Peter
almost never stops screaming he cries
when the family moves into Los Alamos
and he cries at the dinner table these
details are some of the more
fictionalized parts of Oppenheimer but
they serve a greater thematic purpose
after the Manhattan Project the
physicist continues to be played by
screaming albeit the imagined kind as
he's haunted by the horrors of his
creation his children foreshadow all the
Death his inventions ultimately bring I
don't know if we can be interested
weapon once more detailed at the end of
Oppenheimer is that in addition to his
affair with Gene tatlock Oppenheimer
also slept with close friend Ruth
Tallman drawing his marriage to Kitty it
doesn't affect the story all that much
but it's something you might have
expected if you paid attention earlier
in the film Ruth doesn't get a ton of
screen time however she does feature in
a few key moments in one scene before
Oppenheimer is invited to join the
Manhattan Project he's in the room when
Ernest Lawrence and Ruth's husband
Richard begin a meeting concerning the
operation because he isn't clear to know
about it Oppenheimer is asked to leave
and on the way out he tells Richard to
tell Ruth that he'll be up to visit soon
at the time this seems like a harmless
comment to a friend but it could be read
as a hidden jab Tolman gets to be in the
room while Oppenheimer doesn't and we
know from earlier scenes that he's
vindictive later there's a conversation
between Ruth and Oppenheimer at a party
well shorter and less suggestive Mira
zawani has with Kitty earlier in the
movie these Clues foreshadow their
Affair which is only confirmed at the
end
some of the small details in Oppenheimer
are added for dramatic effect but a
surprising percentage of them are pulled
straight from the history books in
addition to the encounter where
Oppenheimer attempts to poison his
instructor at Cambridge his meeting with
Harry S Truman is pretty accurate
according to the Oppenheimer biography
American Prometheus Oppenheimer did
confess to feeling like he had bad blood
on his hands to Truman and the president
did brush him off like he does in the
film drawing the Trinity test the movie
shows Nobel Prize winner Richard Feynman
watching the explosion without
protective glasses as he claims that the
windshield of his truck will protect him
this too is true to life according to
feynman's own account in his
autobiography additionally a lot of
lines in the movie were actually spoken
by the actual people for instance in his
last alamode speech Oppenheimer did say
that he regretted that the bomb couldn't
have been used on the Nazis though it
certainly makes some tweaks Oppenheimer
has a lot of great historical details
that really add to the effect at the
beginning of the film Oppenheimer has
visions of the subatomic World he's
studying Niels Bohr speaks about quantum
physics like it's a magical language
language asking Oppenheimer can you hear
the music however these glimpses of a
magical world give way to more
nightmarish visions of the earth
engulfed in flames during the Trinity
test the first detonation of an atomic
weapon the two meld into one it's easy
to miss but as Oppenheimer stares at the
fire from the Trinity explosion he sees
the glistening particles from his
earlier Visions the crystallized
fragments blow into the Flames creating
a sickening Distortion of the thing that
once gave him so much excitement to
study science in the wake of Trinity
Oppenheimer never again sees a beautiful
Visions from its youth he only sees
Horus fire and Dread throughout
Oppenheimer there are numerous
references to chain reactions nuclear
efficient explosions operate off the
basic concept of a chain reaction and at
one point the Los Alamos scientists
believe there's a chance that an A-bomb
detonation has started chain reaction
that never stops there's a greater than
zero chance before the Trinity test that
the explosion could set fire to the
entire atmosphere effectively destroying
the world it doesn't but Oppenheimer
believes that the Chain Reaction he
started will still end in Armageddon now
I am become death
the destroyer of worlds
going along with this theme the whole
structure of the movie is like a chain
reaction we see how certain decisions
lead to other moments all at once the
beginning middle and end of
oppenheimer's life develop into tandem
with each other giving the impression of
his whole life being a giant explosion
of causality your mileage may vary on
where Oppenheimer ranks in the pantheon
of Christopher Nola movies however one
fact is indisputable the movie feels
like the culmination of many of his past
projects the heavy focus on quantum
physics can be tracked back to
Interstellar which was praised in its
day for being more scientifically
accurate than most Sci-Fi movies the
black and white versus color Dynamic and
non-linear narrative Echo Memento or the
fixation with World War II history
evokes Dunkirk Nolan himself has said
that he sees the ending of Oppenheimer
as being similar to that of inception as
both leave the audience with
unanswerable questions and of course you
could compare the history altering
weapons storyline of tenet to the real
history of the Manhattan Project and
Delta Lee Nolan still has many movies
left to make but the sheer scale of
Oppenheimer puts it on the top shelf of
his filmography given the wide range of
movies a director has helmed thus far it
should be particularly interesting to
see where he goes from here
foreign